dehors une longue file d'attenté pour
accéder à la boutique fleurs et passion
mais la patience a pris le dessus
nombreux voulait repartir avec un
bouquet à l'occasion de la fête des
mères en acheter un petit assortiment de
roseaux toutes les couleurs choisies par
les filles en plus on n'a pas commandé
donc que c'était le jeu lun donc on a
pris on a pris le temps et on a joué
avec les filles à l'intérieur c'est
l'effervescence un record d'affluence
pour cette gérante un événement
important qui demande beaucoup de
préparation pour la gérante et son
équipe ça dure une semaine et ce qui se
passe là c'est vraiment les fleurs les
plus périssables pour avoir les fleurs
les plus fraîches où on met en place on
prépare les commandes les bouquets et
c'est la fête des mères c'est la plus
grosse est que ça soit en chiffres en
préparation en temps de préparation en
organisation en achats et des ventes il
y en avait distance d'un mètre signalé
dans la boutique et gels hydro
alcooliques à la caisse
même en pleine crise sanitaire la fête
des mères restent un moment familial
important
je venais acheté un bouquet de fleurs de
saison pour la fête des mères j'ai pris
une rose aussi pour ma fille dans cette
boutique des enfants parmi eux ibrahim
et ses frères et soeurs composent un
bouquet et 80% des fleurs proviennent de
petits producteurs
un mélange de couleurs de bleu de rouge
deux rouges et deux un petit peu de
violet et blanc parce que c'est la fête
dois remercier toutes les mamans en un
week-end cette fleuriste a réalisé son
plus grand chiffre d'affaires de l'année